bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados
la reina isabel segunda una institución
que marcó por siete décadas a reino
unido falleció el 8 de septiembre
partiendo en dos la historia reciente
del país a qué se debe el éxito de su
reinado qué país recibe carlos tercero y
qué retos enfrenta el nuevo monarca
muchos la consideran la madre y abuela
del reino unido isabel segunda llegó al
trono en 1952 tras la inesperada muerte
de su padre jorge sexto y lideró durante
más de siete décadas la monarquía más
famosa del mundo como se explica que a
pesar de los cambios un sistema de poder
y privilegios hereditarios siga siendo
tan popular y sobre todo que los
contribuyentes sigan financiando la
corona con millonarias sumas sólo en el
último año la monarquía británica costó
a los ciudadanos unos 116 millones de
dólares
isabel segunda es la única reina que han
conocido la mayoría de los británicos
gracias a ella la corona gozó de una
amplia aceptación de acuerdo a una
reciente encuesta de la firma yougov el
62 por ciento de los británicos
consideran que el país debería seguir
una monarquía en 2007 la revista time la
eligió en su lista de las personas más
influyentes del mundo y parte de este
prestigio se debe también a la forma en
la que se desempeñó en el trono si bien
fue la jefa de estado- y todas las leyes
del país debían contar con su firma el
papel del monarca en reinounido es por
así decirlo decorativo y debe mantenerse
en la neutralidad en asuntos políticos
la monarca supo desarrollar este rol a
la perfección sin jamás expresar sus
opiniones en la esfera pública además
supo cerrar las filas de la familia real
a un sinfín de escándalos que rodearon a
la corona desde la infidelidad de su
hijo carlos hacia la princesa diana- el
distanciamiento de harry y megan o las
acusaciones de abuso sexual del príncipe
andrew isabel también impulsó una
narrativa de que todas las personas sin
importar su origen o clase social
formaban parte del reino
algunos autores como mark stone editor
de la bbc- creen que la alta popularidad
de la monarquía británica no es un
asunto de la razón indica que cuando el
imperio británico se desmoronaba la
corona empezó a significar para el
pueblo un reflejo de grandeza y esto ha
quedado arraigado en lo más profundo de
la tradición británica isabel segunda
fue una figura unificadora y no solo en
reino unido sino en todos los países que
componen a la commonwealth la
mancomunidad de naciones está formada
por reino unido y 55 ex colonias
británicas ahora estados soberanos de
los cuales 15 todavía tienen como rey al
monarca de reino unido durante su
mandato la reina logró no sólo mantener
unidas a estas naciones repartidas por
todo el mundo sino que fortaleció
considerablemente los lazos de la
mancomunidad y la expandió que país
recibe carlos tercero el reino unido-
que recibe a carlos tercero no es el
mismo que acogió y sabe el segundo en
1952 un tercio de la población creía que
ella había sido elegida por dios
que en la actualidad la religión ya no
ocupa un lugar central en la vida de los
ciudadanos y en el país viven personas
de múltiples culturas y creencias
diferentes a nivel económico la nación
vive un recrudecimiento de la inflación
y crecimiento de la pobreza además de
enfrentar preocupaciones modernas como
el cambio climático carlos también
recibe un país de más dividido y
polarizado mientras escocia empuja por
un nuevo referendo independentista en
2024 irlanda del norte se paraliza por
los efectos por éxito qué retos enfrenta
carlos tercero tras el fallecimiento de
isabel surgen dudas sobre si carlos
podrá liderar con la misma popularidad
que su madre su deber es mantener la
unión en reino unido- y en la
commonwealth y mantener alto el estatus
de la corona para ello enfrenta varios
desafíos los estados de la commonwealth
han cambiado a lo largo de las décadas y
tras la muerte de isabel segunda quien
los unificó durante y después de esos
procesos de independencia algunos han
dado señas de que podrían romper con la
monarquía y convertirse en repúblicas ya
a finales de 2021 barbados destituyó a
isabel y solo tres días después del
fallecimiento de la monarca antigua y
barbuda indicó que llevara a cabo un
referendo para determinar si carlos debe
continuar siendo su jefe de estado
también tiene como reto lograr la
neutralidad política que se exige a los
reyes británicos a diferencia de su
madre carlos ya ha expresado en diversas
ocasiones su opinión sobre temas de
controversia política esto ha levantado
revuelo en el país y ha sido acusado de
presionar al gobierno en asuntos
políticos así como de invertir en
paraísos fiscales de acuerdo a la
agencia ap sólo el 26 por ciento de los
ciudadanos cree que habrá una monarquía
dentro de 100 años muchas personas
consideran que el reinado de carlos
tercero será profundamente impopular el
nuevo monarca deberá definir qué tipo de
rey moderno será de la misma forma que
isabel segunda tuvo que hacerlo tras los
cambios que trajo el fin de la segunda
guerra mundial su éxito dependerá de
cómo responda a las demandas del mundo
actual y qué tan capaz sea de mantener
los lazos históricos con las antiguas
colonias británicas si les sirve el
vídeo para entender el éxito de la
monarquía británica los esperamos en
otro episodio de en cinco minutos en
france24 france24 puntocom
[Música]